theo tờ politico ngày 20 xong tháng 6 trong bằng bà bị xấu giờ qua, tổng thống Mỹ đồ đơn chăm cùng các trận lý linh tục bắt bỏ, giúp thùng tiêm giò gì từ giới tình bảo Mỹ.
Chồng nó cho rằng chương trình hành nhân của Iran, nhiều khả năng chỉ bị chỉ hoán vài tháng, chỉ không bị xóa số hoàn toàn như tình mố của ông Trump.
Tuy nhiên các trình dạ tình báo và vụ khí hạnh nhân cho rằng, cần nhiều tần thậm chí vài tháng để có thể đánh giá đầy đủ bức độ thiệt hạc.
Vyệt sắc mình đoài hoại thông tin từ các ngồn biệt lặc biệt là từ thực hiện, điều khó thực hiện khi Iran vừa bỏ vio đình chỉ hợp tác với các quan năng lượng của nửa cúp tế, iA.
Chồng khi đó các quan chức Mỹ chỉ khẳng định đã phá hủy các cơ sở làm dầu uran yu m và sẵn xuất nhiên liệu hạt nhân,
mà chưa đưa ra những bằng chứng gió rằng rằng Iran không còn liệu dữ uran yu m được làm dầu hoặc các máy li tâm chưa là đặc.
Một số ngành về tình trước cuộc không tích cho thấy hoặc đậm dây dời tại hai cơ sở bị tấn công là phóc đầu và is phá hàn làm dưới lên ghi ngờ Iran đã sử tán các thành phần thêm chốt trước khi bị Mỹ tấn công.
Theo dưới quan sát, những tình bố mạnh mẽ hiện nay sẽ sớm được kìm chứng trong các cuộc đam phán với Iran.
Nếu dân ra, khi đó không ở đặt ra, là liệu Washington có tích tục giữ lập trường rằng, tây Iran không còn trường trình hạnh nhân,
hãy sẽ phải thương nhận vẫn tổn tại những yu tấu dù dò chưa được giải quyết.